thank you sick for those superb
introductions we will begin this evening
seminar with the Philadelphia Inquirer
series assault on learning for over a
year five reporters from the
Philadelphia Inquirer examine violence
in the city's public schools the public
school system is often hidden from view
it's shielded by locked doors metal
detectors security guards the Inquirer
investigated what lay behind that shield
what they found was shocking every
school day 25 students teachers or staff
members are beaten robbed sexually
assaulted or otherwise victimized by
violent crime the inquiry team did what
no one had done before they revealed the
magnitude of the problem to do this they
poured over reports collected by the
school district they also went through
police reports and records of 9-1-1
calls they found dozens of violent
assaults that the school district had
failed to report they documented how
serious incidents were downgraded to
conceal the severity of the problem
score principals they found often hid
the assaults the reporters interviewed
more than 300 teachers administrators
students and their families they talked
to school district officials police
officers court officials and school
violence experts they found violence
even in preschools where teachers were
assaulted by students or were kids beat
each other up in bloody bras nearly one
in five of the attacks were perpetrated
by students aged 10 or younger
the reporters profiled a ten-year-old
who was charged with assault because he
gave his teacher a black eye but the
Enquirer went beyond that incident
probing the culture of violence and
misery of the neighborhood with the
student lived in an amazing feat of data
journalism the Inquirer created a
database to analyze more than 30,000
serious incidents from assaults to
robberies to rapes that occurred during
the past five years they also worked at
Temple University on a survey that asked
teachers and a
questions about the violence and its
impact on students education in addition
the inquiry team found more than a dozen
school police officers who had been
arrested on drug possession assault
theft and other charges in recent years
one officer with an assault record and
ignored reports of sexual assaults on
teachers on students another had allowed
into the school and angry man who
threatened to attack students through
the gun but the power of this series
does not lie in the data alone it's it
lies in the stories of the students
teachers and parents who struggle with
violence every day these stories were so
horrifying that Philadelphia authorities
promptly took action within five months
the school district superintendent was
replaced and the leadership of the
school district was overhauled schools
began getting serious about reform
violent incidents are now posted online
to prevent principles from suppressing
the numbers a safe schools advocate was
appointed the standards for hiring and
training school cops have been upgraded
Susan Schneider and Mike Leary
congratulations for an amazing series
thanks very much appropriate to our
theme tonight which is holding up the
mirror you held up the mirror to the
Philadelphia school system and the
picture we all saw was not pleasant
before we go into the Nitty Gritty of
this investigation I want to know what
set off this project and how in this age
downsizing and budget cuts how did you
get the Inquirer to commit the time and
resources to an investigation that took
more than a year yeah I think I can help
with that one I'm basically this all got
started because of violent attacks that
occurred at South Philadelphia high
school in December of 2009 and then
number of Asian students were beaten
inside the school outside the school and
the school district was very slow to
react to that and it created there was a
national investigation into that but
basically as horrible as that situation
was it really wasn't all that unusual in
the school district and I covered the
schools for about ten years and had
written lots of stories about
you know what games roaming the school
hallways there was a case of a teacher
who was assaulted by a student and his
neck was broken and it essentially ended
his teaching career so the paper of
course we've written about these stories
but at this time after the attacks at
South Philadelphia high school the paper
decided it was time to really take a
look at violence from every angle
and to look for possible solutions and
really try to address this like we had
never addressed it before and that's why
they ended up assembling a team of five
reporters who they largely detached to
work on this and the team as the team
members itself I think was really
important because you had myself who had
been a beat reporter for ten years the
current beat reporter kristene Graham
Dylan Purcell who was our data guy you
know computer assistant did all the
analysis of the database and then you
had john sullivan who really wanted to
investigate investigate school violence
actually went to the address inside
liked to do this he was one of our top
investigative reporters and finally jeff
damaged who was the reporter who was
able to get himself embedded itself
Philadelphia High School in the
aftermath of those attacks and look at
how a new principal was trying to change
the culture so I mean basically the
paper decided that you know this was
such an important issue our you know
children education or future that we
need it to make that commitment I think
that one of the things to remember is
that every newspaper ought to do this
kind of reporting that y in a timely
straight and resources did we decide to
do this at the inquiry we had a long
tradition it was kind of in our DNA to
do it and I think one of the the things
we did is you know as an editor we
arranged for other people to take over
these beats so we sustained our daily
coverage but there are subjects of such
overriding importance in the community
that we want to get to the bottom of
them and the truth is many stories are
only told because of the dedication of
reporters and because a news
organization commits itself to do it if
we don't do it basically it doesn't get
done and the story wanted to tell as sue
said it's it's kind of a given that in
big city schools there's violence that's
not shocking
to students in the schools they
experience that on a daily basis but it
was shocking to people outside of the
schools and that's really what drove
reform is that even the mayor whose
daughter was in a fairly good public
school at magnet school said I can't
believe this is going on in my own
school district and yet it was every day
like I think one of the unsung heroes an
investigative reporting are the
investigative editors like you're the
investigative Gator better what what is
what was it like you know like her like
the orchestra leader here working with
five reporters and getting them to work
well together and to produce stories
well I I've worked on investigative
series with reporters that didn't even
speak to each other and then that was a
true test of skill and that was actually
a project I did when I was at the
Baltimore Sun and goats of another
Tribune paper in Orlando and remember
the Orlando reporters sent a piece plant
to to my reporter and the first thing he
says it won't work so that took a lot of
that that really took a lot of me to
kind of put that together in this case
it was a lot easier because the
reporters really were a team and they
didn't act jealously and for me it was
more like a ringmaster just coordinating
what they were doing and focusing what
they were doing that at a certain point
people will do a lot of research and
some of the reporters I had were such
maniacs they would still be researching
but you have to say okay I see the shape
of the series I know the forms the
stories need to take here's what has to
get done and there's a deadline
let's not like Luke grant if you
remember that where Billy and Rossi
would for four weeks on the story and
then Luke grant would say well it's two
hours the deadline better get writing
well no I mean realistically this took
weeks to write but I had to say at a
certain point if this is going to be
done and we're gonna do it and we're
gonna do it this way and these are the
stories I think you know Mike won't say
this but his role was crucial to the
series I mean I mean
basically I know as a beat reporter I'd
never been part of investigation like
this before but really it was kind of
like daunting like almost like building
a pyramid you know and I thought that
scared me the idea of building a pyramid
but building a piece of a pyramid day by
day and like going out and finding
something out coming in and telling Mike
about it having mike gear you know steer
and guide really just was you know meant
so much so it's one of them say that
let's talk about the data that was
produced from this project it's amazing
he found 30,000 incidents of series
assault can you tell us where you got
that information
well we obtained the data in part it was
a long struggle to get the data from the
school district which maintained it
records of assault unfortunately they
didn't maintain it in a in a usable form
so it took a lot of time to crunch the
numbers and then you know we didn't
really believe the numbers once we got
them because we came up with additional
information that hundreds and hundreds
of cases were being suppressed and how
did we figure that out we actually found
arrest records police arrest records
where complaints had been made and
police had arrested individuals for
school violence these weren't in the
documents another way we were able to
match up and get more a realistic feel
for the numbers was sue had terrific
sources she developed as a school
reporter and she got thousands of
internal school police records leaked to
her one of the things to remember is is
that this is often a human business that
you get information often because you've
established relationships with
individuals I think you know there's a
lot of younger reporters I sometimes
think I think they can Google things and
the answer is somewhere out there in the
ether or they can file a FOIA and and
that's a good thing both things are good
things there are elements of research
but realistically the reason Sue got a
lot of documentation including a pretty
stunning
video a school security video it's
because she worked sources people knew
her they knew her over a period of time
they trusted her and they knew what she
was doing was important so they they
were glad to a sister you mentioned a
video I'd like us to go through that now
and Sue can you tell us a little bit
about it and how you got it and what
role this video we're going to show a
powerful video which oh this video
played in the story sure
basically the lead case in our series I
was about to shot a herring student at
Auto Reed high school and she was in
class one day taking a test and a group
of students had walked the halls for a
period of time and then rushed into a
classroom and and beat her up and we had
heard about the fact that there was a
video security school security video
that captured the students walking the
halls we knew it existed we knew it had
been used in a court case but we were
had a very difficult time getting it
because it was sealed yes and it wasn't
so basically you know I went to all the
sources that I was turning to normally
and none of them could get it for me
so what I did in the end when Mike said
to me you gotta get that video again we
gotta get it and I'm like what am I
gonna do so I went back to all of my
sources and I said brainstorm with me if
you don't have it who else might let's
broaden the universe where I might look
find this and so finally I found someone
who had the video was willing to give it
to us and it was just you know weeks
before publication I'd like to show it
we'd like to show
on the morning of January 22nd 2010
unread hi student to shot a herring went
to school worried there were signs that
she might be in for trouble a fight she
witnessed but didn't participate in
ominous text messages and Facebook posts
warning of coming attacks to shot it was
so anxious in her first period algebra
class the teacher Michelle Davis sent
her to another room to calm down and
take her tests and she came in very
upset saying saying that she didn't want
to take the test I don't remember
exactly what else she was saying and I
told her she either has a sit down and
take the test quietly or she was gonna
have to leave but went ashada saw girls
engaging in a pre-fight ritual fitting
scarves to their heads and smearing
vaseline on their faces to keep hair
from getting pulled out and faces from
scarring to shot it was sure they were
coming for her I had to watch my son
room so she told me to get out my
classroom angled across the hall and
when I went across the hole they
followed me
but tostada couldn't calm down even in
bryn Keller's classroom she kept looking
out into the hallway eventually to shot
a saw band of fifteen to twenty students
including the girls and head scarves
she'd seen on her way into school
roaming the hallways they looked into
every classroom window they passed
searching for their target to shotta
eventually they spotted her in Keller's
classroom and they burst into the room
it was one male student solid sort of by
a group of students and they came in and
one female every question
and she asked me questions
I guess I didn't give her to read the
answer she wanted so she hit me and then
we sparred we started fighting there
were maybe 10 to 15 students attacking
her with you know a growing number of
students coming into the classroom to
watch the attack left to shot up bloody
and sore chunks of her hair were yanked
out from the front half of her head
there were welts on her face and a lump
under her eye it was important to Takada
that she not show weakness but the
damage to her body was undeniable I mean
the the interesting thing is that in the
security tapes we got we also got a
school security tapes that continued on
for probably another 15 minutes and
there was another fight within three
minutes that in contrast to this one
because the security cameras are on the
hallway so you didn't actually see what
went on the classroom the other one
actually showed a girl getting attacked
in the hallway and falling to the ground
and getting repeatedly kicked and
punched and that one the school security
guards eventually intervened and took
away some of the students in handcuffs
but literally these were two attacks on
different floors of the school within a
few minutes and this is just one school
among 260 schools and while not every
school was affected by violence as you
know you heard earlier what Sheila said
there were 25 incidents like this every
day
in Philadelphia public schools how did
you verify these incidents I mean it's
you had this rare opportunity here
because you had footage from but you had
other stories in that series where you
know you had stories of students
assaulting other students or assaulting
teachers
well in every case that we had we went
to like if it was happened in a certain
school we went to the principal get
their side of the story but the other
thing we also did was we we sat down
with the school district administrators
a couple times during this series I
think it was two or three times and
really present it you wanted to say
here's our findings there's everything
we have we want you to know everything
that's going to be in this series so you
want to hear what you have to say and we
tip it
got from them was alright 30 minutes
gotta go how much time you know really
didn't really don't want to spend a lot
of time with us but it it basically you
know that's more that's that's some of
things we did was we just presented our
findings to you know the principal's the
administrators to get their side of it
and whenever possible we looked for you
know public records to back up the
stories and I think that was you know we
were able to we ended up not having any
corrections in the series well in some
cases they weren't public records also
as I mentioned earlier we got thousands
of internal School District police
reports that recorded these incidents
and pretty specific details so we knew
the names of the perpetrators we knew
the victims names we knew their phone
numbers and addresses and again I'd
emphasize this this was source reporting
this was sue who had established a long
track record of within the schools and
had the confidence of many people who
were willing to give her these kind of
records that allowed us to document what
was going on and and as she said you
know there weren't a corrections I mean
this here was a school district that was
just itching to discredit this series
and it's kind of a lesson for for doing
any kind of strong reporting you know if
there's one small thing that's wrong
people who are aggrieved or who don't
like the results of the series will pick
away with that and seek to discredit it
so we really took a lot of time to
fact-check things but we had a document
for everything one thing one thing that
was really important to I think at the
end was when we did win we got an email
from the school district the new
administration congratulating us and
telling us in an email that we made a
difference in the schools and and we
really could have been paid a higher
compliment this this series dealt with
schoolchildren minors who are both
victims and perpetrators of the violence
what ethical and privacy issues did you
have to deal with you know like
photographing identifying underage
schoolchildren well one thing to
remember actually for reporters is is
that you you do often have access to
juvenile court proceedings they aren't
they aren't sealed and there's a lot of
information to be gained attending those
proceedings and looking at Juvenal
records the availability of data varies
from state to state also in several of
these incidents the perpetrators or the
were charged as adults with with felony
crimes so they weren't necessarily
adjudicated in juvenile proceedings but
we did pay obvious attention to the ages
of some of the individuals and their
identities for example in you did hear
sheila mentioned a ten-year-old boy who
blackened the eye of the teacher we
talked expence extensively to the family
we did not name the child because of his
age we did name the mother who had a
different name which provided a shield
for him while we ran a picture of him it
was not a picture that he could be
identified it was in profile with his
face turning away so we did you know
really draw the line but but also one of
the things we really did try to do which
i think is unusual in a lot of these
series or other depictions of violence
or bullying in schools many accounts
that you will see only speak to the
people who are the victims we made a
special effort to talk to the people who
committed these acts and to sort of
understand why they did that and the one
of the most interesting aspects of the
series was we talked to you know three
young boys who were basically what they
did as they waded into a crowd of
elementary school kids with baseball
bats and wailed on them and they were
playing hooky from school these were
kids who were supposed to be in a school
intervention program which was
essentially a fraud and with the
cooperation of their parents we got
their school files to show that the
schools basically or just pretend
to intervene with them and put them on
the right track so we we spent a lot of
time making sure that you know we
protected the identities or if we used
the identities that we had adequate or
sufficient permissions to use those that
we did interview a number of people
teachers parents who then came back to
us later and said you know I'm
uncomfortable I decided I don't want to
be part of the series and because these
were people who weren't used to dealing
with the press we did honor that and say
okay that's fine we understand that let
me interrupt by asking the audience if
you if you want to ask questions we have
five minutes for questions please go up
to the microphones and identify yourself
while you're doing that I'd like to ask
sue to tell us how she started working
on this series you know sue has been
covering education for many years so
what did you do when you said you know
your paper said we want to do a series
on school violence what did you do next
well I as I covered the school schools
for ten years during that time every
time I went out to do a story whether it
was a feature story trend story whatever
I would always ask the teachers
principals whoever I was interviewing
parents for their cell phone numbers
home numbers and I kept a master list
and so the first thing I did when they
asked me to work on this project was to
call every single person on that list
and ask them for their view of school
violence and that really helped to kind
of give us a base to start to figure out
what was being sent out there what was
happening we found out number of our
incidents through some of that - so
helped out thank you
questions from the audience yes yes
peace one of the stories is Sara you
have to say I'm sorry Sara whites go to
check missed appeal program here at
Columbia one of the stories in your
series profiled a Houston school
district that employed like 400 police
officers as a model of you know a more
effective way of dealing with school
violence and I'm wondering if you did
that in any way to suggest a possible
way of reforming the school system I
know that sort of a
a difficult line that journalists aren't
necessarily supposed to be advocating
any particular solutions do you see that
as what was your thinking and including
that example where you kind of went out
of your way to find this model and then
also your choice to end the series with
South Philadelphia high school the new
principal who was sort of pioneering a
better future well I guess there are a
couple of answers of that one is you
know a lot of journalists just think
they ought to be like veteran Brown and
shoot off a rocket and they shouldn't
care where it lands and we really did
pay attention to best-case solutions and
it isn't necessarily you know having
more police in the schools in fact that
was a follow up story and I'll explain
that in a second in the series what we
did is we found really you have to alter
the climate in the schools and that's
very important and there are strategies
to do that really starting with with
young children and building up through
high school peer mediation and and so on
and we found actually we went to where
as a Palm Beach right in Florida which
has a very effective in school way of
dealing with with incidents of violence
and a much more sure method of dealing
with it one of the problems in
Philadelphia is you constantly have
different principals applying different
remedial measures and there was no
consistency the reason what to Houston
is is that the mayor and the chief of
police said well maybe we should put
armed cops in the schools so we actually
looked for a district that was
comparable in size where they had armed
cops of the schools and Houston was the
district that matched up Philadelphia in
terms of not just size but the makeup of
the student body and actually you know
when we looked at they did a much better
job in Philly you know the one of the
key aspects was they actually screened
their officers and they were profession
I mean we did a story that a follow up
where we were you know you heard about
the no standards for hiring school cops
the lead-off was a cop who was an
admitted crack addict had been in the
crack rehab program was still a school
cop was a two-time loser getting a reign
in her school uniform on the opening day
of school so can we ask both of you to
answer to ask questions quickly are you
both and then we'll have them give a
quick answer because we have to move on
I was just wondering what advice or tips
do you have for maybe a much smaller
news organization a small daily paper
that wants to tackle the same kind of
investigation on much leaner resources
that maybe doesn't have that them as
much people to pour through all the data
coming in are there any tips you have
that you know can this still be done
this level investigation do you think on
a small staff i Michelson we just asked
both of you to ask the questions and it
would get quick answers yeah sure I'm
curious you talked about the the people
that were involved in the schools
themselves but you also talked about a
really successful superintendent that
you ended up getting fired and I'm
really curious to hear about the
interaction you had with her from the
beginning and how that had evolved
toward the later stages of the recording
when it was clear that there was gonna
be this level of wrongdoing showed in
your reports why don't we take the other
question at the end of the panel because
we can then ask all the panelists about
you know what tips would you have for
for news organizations which do not have
the resources to do these kinds of
investigative reporting and then you
take the last okay sure yeah I think I
mean superintendent Arlene Ackerman at
the time one of the reasons we started
looking into this was because of her
response to the incident at South
Philadelphia High School she was she
didn't go to the school for a number of
days after that incident and that really
so so that made us say okay wait a
second we know violence has been a
problem for a very long time but looking
at this response we really feel like we
need to you know take a closer look and
I think you know she pretty much you
know we
the work we were doing at times you know
didn't really want to spend a lot of
time you know talking to us about it but
in the end she had a lot of other issues
that were causing her problems
you know from management to finances it
wasn't it wasn't just eating I mean
Philadelphia's had they've discovered
and we we were the first to document
systemic cheating on their achievement
tests over a long period of time so her
anno claimed that the schools were
getting better every year and year was
was furious thank you